what's up youtubes welcome back to my
channel Richard on data my name is
Richard and this is the channel where we
talk about data so if you've spent a lot
of time in the business analytics the
statistics or the data science world's
before you've probably heard the terms
descriptive analytics predictive
analytics and prescriptive analytics
floating around before now these terms
are generally thought of together in a
pipeline and I don't think that pipeline
is going anywhere in the near future
having said that there are a lot of
misconceptions out there about what
these things are and aren't so I wanted
to talk a little bit about them today as
well as provide some examples of them as
always I humbly request that you smash
the like button if you haven't hit the
subscribe button in the past hit it now
and then hit the notification bell so
you never miss an update all right let's
start with descriptive analytics so
broadly speaking these describe what has
happened in the past and generally when
people use the term exploratory data
analysis these are the kind of analytics
that they're referring to now our
descriptive analytics what you're going
to spend the majority of your time doing
in a data science job it depends
probably not it's not impossible though
it does depend on your job a lot but one
way or the other they're tremendously
useful and you're never going to get
away from doing them at least to some
extent most simple analytics that you
think of will fall under the category of
descriptive analytics so think of things
like your mean your median sums totals
percents percent changes when you're
looking retrospectively at historical
data those are all descriptive analytics
same thing for all your main graphs so
things like bar charts histograms box
plots time charts the dreaded pie chart
all of those things will fall under the
category of descriptive analytics again
when you're looking in the past but wait
there's a little more
so maybe you want to compare some
response between different groups and
you're using confidence intervals or
some kind of hypothesis test that's
another example of a descriptive
analytic maybe you're trying to use an
unsupervised learning technique to
create clusters in your historical data
that's also a descriptive analytic and
then maybe you have a linear or logistic
regression model and you want to infer
the effect that a covariant has on your
response not predict but just make an
inference about an effect that is yet
another example of a descriptive
analytic which brings me to predictive
analytics next now this is a branch of
analytics which provides insight into
what will happen into the future
compared and contrasted with descriptive
analytics which provided insight into
the past now it's important to point out
human beings will naturally take
indications from and make inferences
about the future based on what happened
in the past
now that's complete human nature but
that doesn't make a descriptive analytic
a predictive analytic a predictive
analytic is something which is
specifically formulated for predicting
what is going to happen in the future so
think of things like forecasting models
or classification or regression models
where the goal is explicitly prediction
rather than inference and they're
applied and they're used with that end
goal in mind let's think about linear or
logistic regression so in these
instances maybe we know some covariance
or some information about a subject set
but we don't know some response
well these regression techniques can be
applied to predict that response
that's where predictive analytics shows
up most often in statistical methods but
there's also newer branches in spatial
forecasting models right now and then
maybe you have time series data and then
you can use ARIMA that is auto
regressive integrated moving average or
other variance on it to create a
forecast now if you're looking into
machine learning
most supervised learning or deep
learning methods are going to fall under
the category of predictive analytics as
well now keep in mind it's not
impossible to make a simpler forecasting
or prediction model in fact if you want
to make some assumptions and come up
with some type of business rules and
create a forecast based on those that's
totally fair game and it falls under the
umbrella of a predictive analytic
however the models I described before
they are some of the most common types
of predictive analytics because there's
standard ways of using all available
information and explaining variation in
the system and similarly you have more
complicated variations on predictive
analytics as well so take things like
weather or climate models all of these
things simulate various factors in the
environment and interactions between
these factors and that information is
used to create some type of forecast but
that's well above and beyond what most
people in data science are going to do
as far as predictive analytics is
concerned last but certainly not least
is prescriptive analytics now this is
the holy grail of analytics this is
definitely the rarest branch of
analytics but it definitely has
potential to be the most powerful
because it explicitly tells an end user
what they should do and generally how
this will work is by generating outcomes
from a variety of different scenarios
controlling for risk controlling for
unknowns and uncertainty and then
telling the user what the best scenario
is and like predictive analytics it's
very easy to look at a descriptive
analytic and then get some idea of what
you should do but that doesn't make the
descriptive analytic prescriptive by
definition there are fewer examples of
prescriptive analytics compared to
descriptive or predictive just because
they are the rarest form of analytic
probably the most common form of
prescriptive analytic is a
mathematical optimization model so in
one of these you're typically gonna have
some kind of outcome some features some
constraints and then you can put those
together into an objective function then
that objective function can be used to
compare different combinations different
features different decisions whatever it
may be those comparisons can be made and
then a best option is selected
simulation models are also pretty common
especially in industries like finance or
in healthcare or anything with a supply
chain environment probably the most
common type of simulation is what's
called a Monte Carlo simulation this is
where you use repeated random sampling
to essentially control for unknown
stochastic outcomes so in doing this
you're controlling for volatility and
you're controlling for risk there's also
what's called discrete event simulation
and these serve to model real life
processes as well as the interaction
between different actions or different
events and these can be very powerful
prescriptive analytics as well now once
again with prescriptive analytics just
like with predictive you can come up
with business rules you can fit
statistical distributions for unknown
effects and then you can create a
simpler type of prescriptive analytic
these are probably going to carry with
them a huge amount of assumptions but
you can do this because for a lot of
people you're just going to lack the
know-how or the time to create really
advanced simulation or optimization
models which could take weeks or even
months to produce so these terms are
usually thought of together in a
pipeline and it's pretty easy to
understand why you can't really make a
prediction about the future unless you
understand what happened in the past and
have some kind of idea about why it
happened similarly you can't really tell
somebody what they should do unless you
have some kind of idea or best guess
about what will happen in the future
however this is not always a linear path
you're not always going to go from
descriptive write to predict
if after you're done then after you do
that you go to prescriptive it's often a
lot more cyclical and interwoven and
connected than that you may do a little
bit of descriptive then you do a
predictive model you find some new
things go back to descriptive maybe
decide that you want to delve into
prescriptive go back to descriptive and
predictive after that so on and so forth
so in practice it probably looks a lot
more like a cycle rather than a straight
pipeline so thanks for watching this
video leave me a comment down below and
let me know what you think
until next time Richard on data